bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france des manifestations on l'a vu
qu'ils ont été émaillée de violents
affrontements à paris ce que vous avez
le sentiment vous aussi qu'on vous a
volé votre mobilisation hilaire je sais
pas si on vous la voulez en tout cas il
faut saluer quand même la mobilisation
massive de tous les personnels soignants
ça fait maintenant plus trois mois qu'on
efface cette à ce que cette maladie
qu'ovide les revendications elles seront
portées depuis maintenant suffisamment
mois et de l'allée d'année pour qu'elle
soit qu'elles se verbalise par cette
colère après voilà si je revois juste
les images parce que je découvre les
images en même temps que côté
spectateurs les black box qui sont là y
voilà qui pousse des voitures
les policiers avaient suffisamment les
moyens pour les listes d isoler les
mettre de côté
on s'appelle effet est-ce que c'est une
stratégie derrière j'en sais rien je
souhaite juste la question
ce qui est anormal par contre c'est
qu'on arrive en fin de cortège et que
les personnels soignants qui on n'est
pas des casseurs
on n'est pas les héros on n'est pas des
voyous et on se retrouve finalement
mélangé avec ses black box qui sortent
leurs revendications et leurs façons de
porter leurs revendications ne sont pas
les nôtres mais n'empêche que ce qu'on
retiendra c'est voilà c'est une gêne
bourn a été comment le gaz et il ya eu
des violences
il ya eu des infirmières qui ont été
bousculés il alla qui ont été blessés
bon je sais pas du tout voilà je sais je
peux pas dire qu'on nous a volé notre
mobilisation
par contre je suis en colère oui parce
que voilà les seules images qu'on va
retenir ses lacets images de violence
mais la violence allait au quotidien
dans les hôpitaux et donc ouais je ne
nous a pas volé notre mobilisation nous
a pas parce qu'alors on a répondu
fortement mais par contre et c'est je
suis d'accord négocié que celui-ci
matchs conservant vos revendications
vous qu'il est prouvé au quotidien en
tant qu'infirmier comment est-ce qu'il
faut soigner
l'hôpital public il faut lui donner les
moyens d'exister et l'hôpital public il
ne vit que par
par l'intermédiaire du plan de
financement de la sécurité sociale et
cette plante financement de sécurité
sociale
il est en très grande majorité payer à
un parent à l'impôt sur lequel on paye
dans ma quand j'entends que
gouvernements clients gagnent moins
payer d'impôts il faut comprendre que
les usagers et que le passé les seconds
citoyens français
si honda baisse nos impôts a rapporté
les faits cesse ses locuteurs public qui
vont subir les premières conséquences
derrière
notez quand même que dans les toutes
allocution de maquereau ou de l'envié on
ne fait pas fini d'en faire fi de le 2e
plan de financement de la sécurité
sociale par contre on retarde les moyens
aux territoires de re décidé de se
mobiliser par rapport à l'offre de soins
malheureusement on a bien compris
derrière que les territoires qui sont
plus riches auront plus de facilité pour
avoir les hôpitaux et répondre aux
besoins de la population
pardon excusez moi au plan ségur de la
santé votre syndicat sud-santé a claqué
la porte des discussions pour pour
quelle raison parce qu'elles en sont ces
négociations ou est-ce que ça pêche
selon vous cette pêche parce que malade
nota d'entrée de jeu lara gut et l'a dit
moi j'ai aucun aucune marge de manoeuvre
j'ai pas de donc le budget trg pas de
carnet de chèques donc je serai là juste
pour écouter vos doléances
dites moi de quoi vous avez besoin
coluche avait pour habitude de dire
dites moi de quoi vous avez besoin je
vous dirai comment vous en passer
on a un petit peu la pression que c'est
ça on est dans ce cadre le figure donc
on a bien compris qu'il y avait une
stratégie derrière parce qu'elle a été
utilisée est usitée et abusent et même
par certains gouvernements avant on est
à 15 jours des vacances scolaires d'eau
oui il joue la montre clairement et joue
la montre ils vont noté sur un bout de
papier
les revendications ça nous portera en
septembre et puis d'ici septembre
la face du monde en a changé d'autant
plus que là pour le coup avec
l'actualité internationale quand je vois
ce qui se passe en chine etc
kloster qui remonte risque donc on voit
bien la stratégie clairement définie et
clairement écrite par ce gouvernement
qui est ni plus ni moins de gagner du
temps
l'accession merci avec trek je rappelle
qu apple infirme et membre du syndicat
du site nantais appelé à soutenir
d'autres collègues saïda qui a été
arrêté juste pour faire un trait
d'humour parce que monsieur le wef a
pour habitude de dire qu'ils ne font
jamais de tir tendu de l bd la colonne
ce n'est pas un tir tendu de ne pas dire
est qu'elle a fait elle est arrivée en
cours à la vue des crs qui chargeaient
des infirmières et elle a riposté avec
ses propres moyens
ça peut être effectivement on peut le
dire c'est pas bien oui mais n'empêche
que quand vous êtes pris dans une
situation comme ça voilà donc moi
j'appelle à soutenir farida libéré tard
rapidement notre collègue un chien bien
merci pour votre témoignage électrique
aux infirmiers membres du syndicat cette
santé